[Musique]
on vous présente maintenant notre ca
avec claire bolduc qui présidente de la
chambre de commerce de l'est de montréal
en fait c'est christine fréchette qui
les éclaire baptisé qe préfète de la mrc
de témiscamingue
bonsoir à vous deux alors jaune rouge
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
scccum une très très grand la capitale
nationale sauf portneuf et charlevoix
chaudière appalaches s'est presque 70%
de l'économie du québec qui est en zone
rouge car votre dieu qu'est-ce que c'est
inquiétant pour l'économie de six
régions mais aussi de l'ensemble du
québec
c'est inquiétant pour l'économie aussi
pour la santé des populations
on se rappelle que cette mesure là est
prise sur la recommandation de la santé
publique pour l'économie ce que je
constate c'est que certains services ont
on refuse on ferme certains services
mais on met il d'autres activités
économiques d'importance et ça nous
permettra certainement passer à travers
mais les restaurateurs par exemple où
les bars demande de l'aide ce sera
nécessaire de le faire
j'apprécie aussi que ce soit modulé
comme geste qu'on reconnaisse que des
régions qui ont moins de des clauses ion
que d'autres et qu'en conséquence on est
juste deux façons modules et oui on sort
tout le monde du verre par exemple la
journée même en plusieurs endroits
grenade sud du québec on voit que ça
orange partout est rouge également
hélas les fermes qui aurait pris des
décisions chez nous même avant que ce
soit annoncée de reporter certaines
activités justement parce qu'on
considère que c'est une motivation
c'est un geste de tout le monde s'est
tenue fermée c'est la région du du de
l'abitibi-témiscamingue ce soit c'est la
région de l'abitibi témiscamingue et le
témiscamingue a pris une décision
aujourd'hui de reporter une activité
d'importance parce que c'est tout le
monde qui doit contribuer laquelle les
c'était un raid aventure aurait dans ses
aventures
parfait christine kristin fermeture des
salles à manger des restaurants des bars
des salles de spectacles des cinémas des
théâtres des bibliothèques des musées
pendant quatre semaines
est-ce que c'était la chose à faire pour
je comprends que le gouvernement veuille
agir parce qu'il ya une hausse de cac
significative au cours des derniers
jours mais j'ai l'impression qu'on cible
des secteurs d'activité qui ne sont pas
nécessairement liés au rehaussement des
codes qu'ovide qu'on a vu ces derniers
temps
si je m'en remets par exemple à la
docteure drouin qui est la directrice la
santé publique à montréal
elle disait la semaine dernière que les
quatre principales sources des nouvelles
éclosions étaient les milieux de travail
les établissements scolaires les centres
de garder le milieu de la santé
donc aucun de ces milieux là finalement
ne fait l'objet d'une restriction
beaucoup plus marqué aujourd'hui donc ça
fait en sorte qu'on cible des
entreprises des organisations qui
n'étaient pas nécessairement liés mais
aussi donner des exemples précis comme
disait monsieur mais une idée des
restaurants du québec tantôt on veut
faire un symbole en quelque sorte des
choses qui sont faciles à comprendre
voici on ferme des restaurants ont fait
le débat c'est l'impression que ça donne
on veut prendre les devants peut-être
sur le rehaussement de cov futur que
l'on craint donc il ya peut-être plus de
70 ans y ont là mais comme si la voie
qu'ont pour laquelle on a opté je pense
qu'il est vraiment important que le
gouvernement énonce dès cette semaine si
possible les mesures de soutien qu'il
offre au secteur qui s'occupe de tout
fermer sa part alors on peut penser à
une aide pour payer les frais fixes
les restaurants les bars les musées ils
ont des frais fixes importants ce que le
gouvernement peut venir en soutien pour
le paiement de ses frais fixes il ya
beaucoup de programmes également de
prêts qui ont été développés par le
gouvernement du québec ça d'ailleurs été
davantage la proche plutôt que celle du
fédéral d'octroyer des prêts est ce
qu'on pourrait transformer une partie de
ses prêts en subvention de telle sorte
qu'on ne vient pas seulement alourdir le
fardeau fiscal que ces organisations et
entreprises auront à payer
est-ce que c'était juste claire bolduc
je vais vous poser la question aux 12
aces que possible et justement certains
secteurs bien qu'il faille agir compte
tenu de la hausse des cas est ce qu'il
ya une forme d'injustice de l'essai par
exemple les salons de coiffure
li jim ouvert alors qu'on ferme les bars
et les restaurants claire baude yeux
c'est dans les particulièrement les bars
et dans ces endroits là où les gens
perdent certaines inhibitions et c'est
probablement pour cette raison là qui
sont particulièrement ciblés les bars
les casinos je comprends moins les
musées mais où les bibliothèques mais
dans des lieux où les gens se
rassemblent se retrouvent et où on peut
face plus facilement perdre certaines
émissions ou laisser-aller certaines
bonnes habitudes
on rappelle que c'est un virus qu'on
connaît qu'on apprend connaître quand on
a encore très mal bon et qu'on connaît
pas du tout sur le long terme qu'on cite
trois mesures très très importante à
appliquer que sont la distanciation
physique le port du masque quand on se
déplace et le lavage des mains alors et
dans les circonstances les éclosions
sont apparus lorsque les inhibitions
tombaient par exemple dans les fêtes
étudiantes absolument christine est ce
qu'on vient de signer l'arrêt de mort de
plusieurs entreprises
est ce qu'il ya une forme d'injustice
dans tout cela si on ne fait pas des
mesures de soutien très rapidement de
manière très claire c'est sûr qu'il y
aura beaucoup d'entreprises qui ne
pourront pas traverser cette nouvelle
crise on était au tout début de cette
reprise
là c'est sûr qu'on vient reporter la
réouverture de plusieurs secteurs
notamment de la métropole
on pense au centre-ville notamment c'est
pas avec la fermeture des restaurants
que l'on va ramener des gens dans les
tours à bureaux au centre-ville
donc c'est sûr qu'on vient ralentir la
relance économique convient aussi mettre
un terme à plusieurs entreprises à moins
qu' on ne la réplique rapidement ce à
quoi ils auront droit et que l'on lorgne
octroient ces aides rapidement andriole
nous le montrer en début d'émission les
cas augmentent mais la situation au
québec est quand même bien meilleur que
d'un presque totalité des états
américains bien meilleurs que la france
que les états unis l'ensemble du canada
aussi en termes de cas par million
d'habitants on est relativement bas je
ne suis pas en train de minimiser au
contraire c'est toujours en train de
monter la question est ce qu'on agit
peut-être trop rapidement et trop
fortement
ou au contraire par prévention on agit
vite on frappe forte le club odieux on
agit vite on frappe fort et je pense que
c'est le geste à poser dans le contexte
si on voit l'augmentation très rapide on
se souvient que c'est une courbe
exponentielle savez bien est expliquée
sur vos ongles que c'est un corps qui
transmet une personne à chaque jour 24
jours 6 7 millions de personnes qu'on ne
pouvait alors je pense que c'est le bon
geste à poser maintenant qu'on agit de
la bonne manière en faisant très
directement très fortement de façon
module est également question mais je
pense qu'il faut agir mais je pense
qu'il faut agir de manière plus marquée
dans les zones qui font l'objet des
catégories rouge maintenant en ciblant
les secteurs qui ont été ciblés par le
gouvernement les salles de spectacle les
restaurants les bars et tout ça je pense
qu'on a ciblé indûment des secteurs qui
n'était pas nécessairement en lien avec
les nouvelles sources éclosion je crois
qu'il faut y aller de nouvelles méthodes
on parle notamment d'une application de
traçabilité est ce que le gouvernement
devrait mettre de l'avant je pense que
peut-être la solution rien penaud vers
les prochains jours dit on on va suivre
ça de près christine clerc merci
beaucoup merci merci